From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，正在为您播出《美国生活》，本节目由国际公共电台发行。
OK, so we're looking at 2010. Next year. What does your higher power want you to know? Asking your higher self to guide your hands. What does that look like, 2010?
好的，我们来看看 2010 年。明年。你的“高等自我”想要告诉你什么？请求你的“高等自我”引导你的双手。2010 年会是什么样子？
In the back room of a crystal shop in San Francisco, a spiritual adviser named Joa Marcu is doing a tarot card reading for a woman named Ashli Lewis. In her car on the way to the reading, Ashli explained to me why she was going at all. She's not somebody who especially believes in psychics and readers and all that, but going now and then over the last decade and a half, she has always gotten the same exact message from these people.
在旧金山一家水晶店的后室里，一位名叫乔亚·马库（Joa Marcu）的精神导师正在为一位名叫阿什莉·刘易斯（Ashli Lewis）的女士解读塔罗牌。在去往水晶店的车上，阿什莉向我解释了她为什么要来这里。她并不是那种特别相信通灵者或占卜师之类的人，但在过去十五年里，她偶尔也会去占卜，而且每次从这些人那里得到的预言都完全一样。
You're going to be incredibly successful. And usually it came with the addition that I would be incredibly wealthy.
你会获得巨大的成功。而且通常还会加上一句，我会变得非常富有。
Also sometimes-- famous. And not just sort of successful or somewhat wealthy or semi-famous. The prediction is always to the max.
有时还会说——会变得出名。不仅仅是那种程度的成功、小有资产或是小有名气。预言总是说会达到极致。
The first time it happened was in 1996. She was at South By Southwest in Austin, and a friend had dragged her to an astrologer's table there.
第一次发生是在 1996 年。当时她在奥斯汀的“西南偏南”大会（South By Southwest），一位朋友硬拉着她去了一个占卜师的摊位。
And the guy, you know, he quickly did my chart or whatever. And all of a sudden he goes, oh my god. He goes, I knew somebody would be walking around this weekend with this chart. He goes, you're the one. He goes, big, big money. Big, big money. Incredible success.
那个家伙，你懂的，他很快排出了我的星盘之类的东西。突然间他惊呼道，天哪。他说，我早就知道这周末会有带着这张星盘的人四处走动。他说，就是你了。他说，会有大笔大笔的钱。大笔大笔的钱。难以置信的成功。
And I'm just kind of-- I kind of go-- well, I didn't really think much of it at all.
我当时就有点——我当时觉得——好吧，我根本没把这当回事。
A few years later, on her 35th birthday, she took a trip to Santa Fe. Decided to go to a psychic as a birthday treat to herself. And this woman made the same prediction during the reading.
几年后，在她 35 岁生日时，她去了一趟圣达菲。决定去见一位灵媒作为送给自己的生日礼物。结果那位女士在解读时也做出了同样的预言。
But it didn't really hit me until I was leaving her house and I was walking away, and I'm walking down the street. And she chases after me, and she catches up with me, and she's like, look. She says, I have to make you understand something. She says, I don't think you get what I'm talking about. She says, when I tell you you're going to be successful, I don't mean kind of successful. I mean successful in a way that you rarely see. I mean really successful, and you just need to get ready.
但我直到离开她家走在街上时才真正受到冲击。她追了出来，赶上我，她说，听着。她说，我必须让你明白一件事。她说，我不认为你听懂了我在说什么。她说，当我告诉你你会成功时，我指的不是那种程度的成功。我指的是你鲜少见到的那种成功。我指的是真正的成功，你只需要做好准备。
Two years later, Ashli was visiting Seattle and, yet another reader delivers exactly the same message. Massive success, massive wealth, massive fame. And Ashli asked this woman, why is this always the same wherever she goes? And the woman said, your spirit guide is really, really loud. It's like he's behind you, yelling this at me.
两年后，阿什莉去西雅图旅游，又有一位占卜师说了完全相同的话。巨大的成功、巨大的财富、巨大的名望。阿什莉问这位女士，为什么她走到哪里听到的都是一样的话？那位女士说，你的精神向导非常、非常吵。就像他一直站在你身后，对我大喊着这些预言。
Ashli says that she's not even somebody who wants spectacular money or fame. She's still a skeptic about psychics, though she says that she's had a few predictions come true in spooky ways. Like when she was 18, a friend dragged her to see this old woman who didn't take money and supposedly had a gift from God-- seeing the future.
阿什莉说，她甚至不是那种渴望惊人财富或名声的人。她对通灵者依然持怀疑态度，尽管她说自己确实经历过一些以诡异方式成真的预言。比如她 18 岁时，一个朋友硬拉她去见一位不收钱的老妇人，据说她有上帝赐予的天赋——能预知未来。
She said to me, do you know a Bill? And I remembered later thinking, you know, that's such a common name. But I really don't know a Bill, except for this ex-boyfriend, a friend of mine. And she said, Bill Mc-, Mc-something Irish. Don't worry, you will. And my husband is Bill Mc- Mc-something Irish.
她对我说，你认识叫比尔的人吗？我后来记得当时想，这名字太常见了。但我真的不认识叫比尔的人，除了那个曾是我男朋友的朋友。她说，比尔·麦克……麦克什么的爱尔兰姓氏。别担心，你会认识的。结果我丈夫就叫比尔·麦克……麦克什么什么的爱尔兰姓氏。
What is his name?
他叫什么名字？
Bill McLachlan.
比尔·麦克拉克兰（Bill McLachlan）。
And what was your relationship with him at the time? Like, what did you know about him?
当时你和他是什么关系？比如，你当时对他了解多少？
Oh, I didn't meet him for like another four years after that, three years. It was later that I remembered that she had asked me that question.
哦，那之后又过了大概三年、四年我才遇见他。后来我才想起她问过我那个问题。
Creepy, right?
毛骨悚然，对吧？
So another seer told Ashli that her money and her fame would happened by the time that she's 50 years old, and she's 46 now, and she figured, OK. Time is running out. 2010 really might be the year. 2010 could be when this is all going to go down. And the only question was, how?
所以另一位先知告诉阿什莉，她的财富和名声会在她 50 岁之前到来，她现在 46 岁了，她心想，好吧。时间不多了。2010 年真的可能是那一年。2010 年可能是这一切发生的年份。唯一的问题是，怎么实现？
So can I ask you, are you thinking, like, OK, maybe you're going to go on American Idol ?
我可以问问你吗，你有没有在想，好吧，也许你会去参加《美国偶像》？
I'm past the age requirement.
我年龄超标了。
Like, would you ever go on a reality show?
比如，你会去参加真人秀吗？
No.
不。
Have you been thinking about sleeping with the president?
你有没有在考虑和总统睡觉？
Not the current one, and can't say the last one either. So no.
不是现任的那位，上一位也不行。所以，不。
All right. So to begin our reading, Ashli, what I want you to do--
好的。那么开始解读吧，阿什莉，我希望你做的是——
Which brings us back to the crystal shop. It's been five years since Ashli's had a reading. She's had a baby since the last time. Her life has changed a lot. And she came here because she wants to know if her fate has changed, also. Maybe she's no longer destined for money and fame.
这就把我们带回了水晶店。阿什莉已经有五年没做过解读了。自从上次之后她生了个孩子。她的生活发生了很大变化。她来这里是因为她也想知道自己的命运是否改变了。也许她注定不再拥有财富和名声。
And what she hears from Joa is disappointing. Mostly the reading just seems really, really generic. Joa tells her that there's something new and hopeful on the horizon for Ashli in 2010, but force inside her, negativity, is blocking this from happening.
而她从乔亚那里听到的结果令人失望。大多解读听起来非常、非常笼统。乔亚告诉她，2010 年阿什莉的前方有新的希望，但她内在的一种力量，即负面情绪，正在阻碍这一切发生。
There's a part of you, a judging part of you, says no. Who do you think you are. You know, whatever that negative voice is.
你内心有一部分，那部分批判性的自我，在说不。你以为你是谁啊。你知道的，无论那种负面声音是什么。
No mention of wealth. No mention of fame.
没有提到财富。没有提到名声。
Outside on the street, afterwards, Ashli tells me that despite all that, despite Joa's reading, she still thinks she's heading for that fate that all the other psychics have predicted. Maybe in 2010, maybe not.
事后在街上，阿什莉告诉我，尽管如此，尽管听了乔亚的解读，她仍然认为自己正在走向其他灵媒预言的那个命运。也许在 2010 年，也许不是。
So you think you're going to have a good year?
所以你认为你会过个好年？
Oh, I always have a good year.
哦，我每年都过得很好。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. It always gets better for me.
是的。我的生活总是越来越好。
I suppose if you're going to go to psychics, this is a sensible way to do it. Ashli will look into a crystal ball and then she'll pick and choose what to believe about what it reveals. Which happens a lot this time of year.
我想如果你非要去找灵媒，这倒是一种明智的做法。阿什莉会去看水晶球，然后从中挑选她想相信的内容。每年的这个时候，这种情况很常见。
We got the idea for today's radio show from some conversations that I had with guy from The Economist magazine. The Economist, once a year, heads out on this mission to see into the future. They try to predict the coming year. All of their editors, all their writers devote a full issue to this.
我们制作这期节目的灵感来自于我和《经济学人》杂志一位员工的交谈。《经济学人》每年都会开启一项预测未来的使命。他们试图预言接下来的一年。他们所有的编辑和作者都会为此花费整整一期的时间。
I am a fan of the Economist . I'm a subscriber. It's well-written, it's well-edited. I like the voice of the magazine. And full disclosure, they've been an underwriter of our show now and then.
我是《经济学人》的粉丝。我是订阅用户。它写得很好，编辑得也很棒。我喜欢这本杂志的口吻。而且提前说明一下，他们偶尔也会赞助我们的节目。
That said, I think this project where they predict the coming year, it's totally ridiculous. You have these great reporters who have to write about, for instance, what's going to happen in China in the year 2010, and they bring so much knowledge to this question. But in the end, because no one can know the future, they end up making these kind of equivocal-- on the one hand, on the other hand-- kinds of predictions. "China wants to be respected as a world power, but it doesn't want to do the things that a great world power does, and so it stands at a crossroads." Who cares?
话虽如此，我觉得他们预测来年的这个项目简直荒谬至极。你有这些伟大的记者，他们不得不写比如“2010 年中国会发生什么”，他们确实为这个问题带来了丰富的知识。但最终，因为没有人能预知未来，他们写出来的全是模棱两可的——一方面，另一方面——那种预测。“中国希望被视为世界大国，但它不想做世界大国该做的事，所以它站在了十字路口。”谁在乎呢？
As a reader, you're basically in the same position that Ashli is in. There's a bunch of contradictory things that might or might not happen. Believe whichever you want.
作为一个读者，你基本上处于和阿什莉同样的位置。有一堆可能会发生也可能不会发生的相互矛盾的事情。你想相信哪个就相信哪个。
And here at our radio show we thought, what if somebody tried to forecast the coming year, but instead of those "maybe it'll be this way, maybe it'll be that way" kinds of essays that you see everywhere this time of year, what if they went for real predictions? Real predictions of things that are actually, no kidding, going to happen this year? To them, to people they know?
我们节目组就在想，如果有人试图预测来年，但不是那种每年这个时候随处可见的“也许会这样，也许会那样”的文章，而是预测真实的事情呢？真正地、毫无疑问地会在今年发生的事情？对他们自己，对他们认识的人？
And so that's what we're doing. Today we have five predictions in five acts, including a death, a birth, a sixth grader's fate in school, and just for some scope, the fate of the Middle East.
所以这就是我们正在做的。今天我们在五个章节里有五个预言，包括一场死亡、一次出生、一个六年级学生的学校命运，以及为了更有广度，还有中东的命运。
Want to see the future? Want to see what 2010 holds? Well, stay with us.
想看看未来吗？想看看 2010 年会有什么吗？好吧，请继续收听。
Act One. "Chronicle of a Death Foretold." We start with this look into the coming year from Shalom Auslander.
第一章。“一场预告的死亡纪事”。我们首先从 Shalom Auslander 对来年的审视开始。
2010 is not going to be a good year for me, mostly because it's going to be a terrible year for my friend Lisa, who's going to die. That's what the doctors say. Three months ago, they gave her six months to live. Lisa, according to the doctors, will die sometime in late February, possibly early March.
2010 年对我来说不会是好年头，主要是因为它对我的朋友丽莎（Lisa）来说将是可怕的一年，她要死了。医生是这么说的。三个月前，医生说她只剩下六个月的生命。根据医生的说法，丽莎会在 2 月底到 3 月初之间的某个时候去世。
The day after the doctors gave her the news, her husband Jason came over to our house. Jason and Lisa are our next door neighbors. My wife and I don't like people as a rule, so it was something of a miracle that we don't just like Jason and Lisa, that they are two of our favorite people in the world, and live right next door. Our list of favorite people is a short one, approximately two people. And by late February, possibly early March, that list is going to be cut right in half.
医生告诉她这个消息的第二天，她丈夫杰森（Jason）来了我家。杰森和丽莎是我们隔壁的邻居。我和妻子通常不喜欢与人打交道，所以我们不仅不讨厌杰森和丽莎，反而他们是我们世界上最喜欢的两个人，而且就住在隔壁，这简直是个奇迹。我们最喜欢的人名单很短，大约只有两个人。而到 2 月底或 3 月初，这份名单将直接砍掉一半。
Six months, said Jason. And though it's news I knew would eventually come, I began to feel faint. Lisa has stage four metastatic cancer. On the plus side, ten years ago, the doctors gave her two years to live. Five years ago, they gave her just one year to live. I am trying to remain hopeful. Perhaps in another two years, they'll give her thirty seconds to live, and she can just prove them all wrong one more time, before even leaving the exam room.
六个月，杰森说。虽然这是我知道迟早会来的消息，但我还是开始感到头晕。丽莎患的是四期转移性癌症。好的一面是，十年前，医生说她只有两年寿命。五年前，他们说她只剩一年。我尽量保持乐观。也许再过两年，他们会说她只剩 30 秒寿命，然后她就能在离开检查室之前，再次证明他们全都错了。
I hugged Jason. We tried not to cry.
我拥抱了杰森。我们尽量不哭。
When he leaves, my wife is crestfallen. She's inconsolable. I try to console her. "Screw 'em," I said. "Maybe Lisa is one of those stories you always hear about, where the doctors give someone a week to live and they live ten more years." "She was one of those stories," said my wife, "ten years ago."
当他离开时，我妻子垂头丧气。她伤心欲绝。我试着安慰她。“去他们的，”我说。“也许丽莎就是你常听到的那种故事，医生说人只有一周寿命，结果他们又活了十年。”“她十年前就是那种故事，”我妻子说。
She had a point. Eventually, if you follow them long enough, even the happiest stories end unhappily.
她说的有道理。最终，如果你追踪得足够久，即使是最幸福的故事也会有不幸的结局。
I was a child when my grandmother's older sister Henni died. Baba, as we called our grandmother, was already in her 70s, and was suffering from Alzheimer's disease. There was a memorial service at our home. Everyone was sad except for Baba, who came through the front door, saw the house full of people, and assumed it was a surprise birthday party for her.
我还是个孩子时，祖母的姐姐亨尼（Henni）去世了。芭芭（Baba），也就是我们对祖母的称呼，当时已经 70 多岁了，患有阿尔茨海默症。家里举行了悼念仪式。除了芭芭之外所有人都很悲伤，她从前门进来，看到屋子里全是人，以为是大家在为她举办生日惊喜派对。
This is my first experience with the ending of life, and watching Baba, it seemed that dementia was a pretty good way to go through it. Baba smiled and clapped and thanked everyone for coming. Then my mother took her aside, sat her on the couch in the den, and gave her the news that her sister Henni had died. Baba gasped, pulled her hair, and began to wail. "Oh, Henni," she cried. "Henni, Henni, Henni!" My mother held her and stroked her hair and asked me to get her a glass of water.
这是我第一次接触死亡的终结，看着芭芭，我觉得痴呆症似乎是一种度过余生的不错方式。芭芭笑着拍手，感谢大家的到来。然后我母亲把她拉到一边，让她坐在客厅的沙发上，告诉了她亨尼去世的消息。芭芭倒吸一口凉气，揪住头发，开始哀嚎。“哦，亨尼，”她哭喊道。“亨尼，亨尼，亨尼！”母亲抱着她，抚摸着她的头发，让我去给她倒杯水。
After a few minutes Baba had recovered. She asked me if I was in school and if I liked it. I told her that I was, and that I did. And then she smiled and apologized and asked me who I was.
几分钟后芭芭恢复了平静。她问我还在上学吗，喜欢上学吗。我告诉她我在上学，也很喜欢。然后她微笑着道歉，问我是谁。
I was about to answer her when a well-meaning guest approached and gently clasped Baba's hand. "Pearl," he said, "I'm so sorry about Henni." "What about Henni?" asked Baba. "What happened to Henni?"
我正要回答她，一位好心的客人走过来，轻轻握住芭芭的手。“珀尔（Pearl），”他说，“对于亨尼的事我很难过。”“亨尼怎么了？”芭芭问。“亨尼出什么事了？”
It was a rough morning for Baba. There was much gasping, much pulling of hair, and much wailing. Every time she forgot about her sister, another well-meaning cousin came over, expressed his condolences, and tore Baba's heart out anew. Perhaps, I quietly suggested to my mother, everyone should just keep their stupid best wishes to themselves. At last, they did.
对芭芭来说这是一个艰难的早晨。又是一阵倒吸凉气、揪头发和哀嚎。每当她忘记她姐姐的事时，另一个好心的表亲就会过来，表达哀悼，又一次撕碎了芭芭的心。我悄悄向母亲建议，也许大家应该把那些愚蠢的慰问留给自己。最终，他们真的这么做了。
Baba, for her part, stayed on the couch in the living room, smiling, sipping her water, and enjoying her birthday party. "This really is such a nice surprise," she said to me. "It's a great party," I said. "Everyone's here," she said. "They love you," I replied. Baba looked up at me and smiled. "And who are you?" she asked.
芭芭则坐在客厅的沙发上，微笑着，喝着水，享受着她的生日派对。“这真的是一个巨大的惊喜，”她对我说。“这派对真棒，”我说。“大家都在这里，”她说。“他们爱你，”我回答。芭芭抬头看着我笑了。“你是谁？”她问。
In the other room, people sobbed. I moved a pillow aside and sat down beside Baba, preferring the joyful company of the delusional to the miserable company of the sane.
在另一个房间里，人们啜泣着。我移开一个靠垫，坐在芭芭身边，宁愿陪伴在快乐的妄想者身边，也不愿待在悲惨的正常人中间。
By mid-January, Lisa will be getting worse. She won't come out much, not even up to our place for the occasional dinner. Jason's voice will sound wearier if he even answers the phone, and by February, we probably won't hear from him at all. Perhaps they just want to be alone together. Perhaps they've put their trays up, assumed the crash position, and are waiting for impact.
到 1 月中旬，丽莎的情况会恶化。她不会怎么出门，甚至不会来我们家吃偶尔的晚餐了。杰森的声音听起来会更疲惫，如果他还会接电话的话；到了 2 月，我们可能根本联系不上他了。也许他们只想独处。也许他们已经收拾好餐盘，做好了坠毁的姿势，等待着冲击的到来。
That's about when I'll begin to get angry at science. "It's 2010," I'll complain, "and they can't even cure cancer? How goddamn hard can that be?"
那差不多就是我开始对科学感到愤怒的时候。“现在是 2010 年了，”我会抱怨，“他们居然连癌症都治不好？这到底能有多难？”
By early March, I imagine, I'll start reading philosophy books, the more miserable and convoluted the better, looking for answers. The something something of existence, or the whatever-otics of mortality. I'll go to the information counter at the bookstore and ask for invented titles that sound like the kind of book I'm looking for.
我想到了 3 月初，我会开始阅读哲学书籍，越痛苦、越晦涩的越好，寻找答案。关于存在的某某，或者是死亡的什么学。我会去书店的信息台，询问那些听起来像是我在寻找的书的虚构书名。
Do you have a book called Death Without Sorrow? How about Why Life is Relentlessly Cruel and Terminally Oppressive? Not sure of the author.
你们有叫《无悲伤的死亡》的书吗？或者《为什么生活如此残酷且具压迫性》？不记得作者是谁了。
My grandfather, Baba's husband, was one of the kindest people in my life. We called him Zaida. Zaida always seemed to make the best of any situation, to keep positive even in the face of unrelentingly negative situations. When Baba's Alzheimer's progressed beyond a manageable point, he moved with her into a home for the aged. She lived upstairs with the patients, and he lived downstairs with the spouses.
我的祖父，也就是芭芭的丈夫，是我生命中最善良的人之一。我们叫他扎伊达（Zaida）。扎伊达似乎总能从任何情况中找到最好的出路，即使面对不可动摇的负面情况也能保持乐观。当芭芭的阿尔茨海默症发展到无法应对的地步时，他随她搬进了一家养老院。她住在楼上病房，他住在楼下配偶区。
I was 17 and went to visit them after school on Friday afternoons. Sometimes sitting in his room beside his bed, you could hear them up there, the demented, the delusional, the dying, yelling and cursing and crying out. Fortunately, while the patients upstairs were losing their minds, the spouses downstairs were losing their hearing, and there wasn't a television on the floor that wasn't set to maximum volume.
我 17 岁那年，每周五放学后会去看望他们。有时坐在他床边，你能听到楼上那些痴呆的、妄想的、将死的人在尖叫、诅咒和哭喊。幸运的是，当楼上的病人在失去理智时，楼下的配偶们正在失去听力，而且那一层没有一台电视机的音量不是开到最大的。
Zaida would ask me about school and we'd talk about my plans for after graduation. Baba and Zaida had been married for over 50 years, and he visited her up there every day. He joked about the nonsensical things she said to him, the insults she flung at the nurses. He gave me hope. If he could find laughter in this hell, maybe there could be hope for us all. Maybe death didn't have to destroy the life around it.
扎伊达会问我学校的情况，我们会聊聊我毕业后的打算。芭芭和扎伊达结婚超过 50 年了，他每天都会去楼上看她。他会开玩笑说她对他说的那些荒唐话，她对护士们喷出的侮辱。他给了我希望。如果他能在地狱中找到欢笑，也许我们所有人就都有希望。也许死亡不必摧毁它周围的生活。
And then Baba died. Zaida refused to walk. He refused to get out of bed. One of his toes became gangrenous and the doctors removed it.
然后芭芭去世了。扎伊达拒绝走路。他拒绝起床。他的一根脚趾坏疽了，医生切除了它。
I went to visit them. I told him about school and what I planned to do after graduation.
我去看望他们。我告诉他关于学校的事，以及毕业后的计划。
"It's a lie," he said. "What?" I asked. "The golden years," he replied. "There's nothing golden about the golden years." And then he died.
“那是谎言，”他说。“什么？”我问。“黄金岁月，”他回答。“黄金岁月里什么都没有。”然后他去世了。
Getting together is not my thing. I could do without getting together. I'd rather be stuck in an elevator. At least in an elevator, most people agree they'd rather not be there, and there's no obligation to talk. You're not even really supposed to. Just find somewhere to stand, shut up, stare at the wall, and it will soon be over, which is basically how I handle get togethers.
聚会不是我的强项。我宁可不去参加。我情愿被困在电梯里。至少在电梯里，大多数人都同意他们不想待在那里，而且没有说话的义务。甚至根本不应该说话。找个地方站好，闭嘴，盯着墙看，很快就会结束，这基本上就是我处理聚会的方式。
By April, though, assuming the doctors were right, Lisa will be dead, and her friends will be getting together with alarming regularity. Dinners in, dinners out, barbecues, pool parties. I'll have to go, of course, because it will be for Lisa, and it will be what Lisa would have wanted.
不过到了 4 月，假设医生说得对，丽莎就会去世，她的朋友们会以惊人的频率聚会。在家里吃晚餐，出去吃晚餐，烧烤，泳池派对。我当然得去，因为那是为了丽莎，也是丽莎想要的方式。
Not that anyone will talk about Lisa. In fact, everyone will be careful not to talk about Lisa, because these parties will be about celebrating life, about joy, and friendship, and moving on.
并不是说有人会谈论丽莎。事实上，每个人都会小心翼翼地不去谈论丽莎，因为这些派对是为了庆祝生命，为了快乐、友谊和继续前行。
There will be a lot of laughter. Too much laughter. That laughter in the face of tragedy kind of laughter that isn't really laughter at all, and which will annoy me, since I work really hard to make people laugh, and here people are getting big laughs just because someone's dead, which shouldn't count.
会有很多欢笑。太多的欢笑。那种面对悲剧时的欢笑，其实根本不是欢笑，这会让我很恼火，因为我努力工作就是为了让人们笑，而这些人仅仅因为有人死了就大笑不已，这根本不算数。
Lisa was a vegetarian, and I'll decide to get in on the easy laughter by making some joke about, hey, at least now we don't have to worry about making veggie burgers, am I right? There will be uncomfortable silence, and I'll feel like a dick, so I'll find somewhere to stand, shut up, and stare at the wall. Soon it will be over.
丽莎是个素食者，我会决定通过开玩笑来加入那种廉价的笑声，比如，嘿，至少现在我们不用担心做素食汉堡了，对吧？会有尴尬的沉默，我会觉得自己像个混蛋，所以我就会找个地方站好，闭嘴，盯着墙看。很快就会结束了。
By May, it will be almost three months since Lisa died. In the warmer months, I like to ride my bike to work, but I'll feel guilty passing Lisa's house while engaged in something so healthy and alive, so I'll put my bike in my car, drive past the house, park at the end of the road, and ride from there. It'll be an incredible hassle, and by the middle of May, I'll think about moving. I've always liked Seattle.
到 5 月，丽莎去世就快三个月了。在温暖的月份里，我喜欢骑自行车上班，但我经过丽莎家时会感到内疚，因为我正在做如此健康且充满活力的事情，所以我就会把自行车放进车里，开车经过她家，把车停在路尽头，然后从那里开始骑。这太麻烦了，到 5 月中旬，我会考虑搬家。我一直很喜欢西雅图。
I get over my guilt by June, but Lisa is an avid gardener, and around the middle of the month, her friends will decide that maintaining her garden would be a beautiful and life-affirming gesture, one that Lisa would want. They'll start showing up every weekend to weed, prune, and water Lisa's garden. They'll make a sign, brightly colored, that reads "Lisa's Garden," complete with butterflies, and a rainbow, maybe a sunrise. And by July, there will be at least one of them working there every goddamn day of the week.
到了 6 月我克服了内疚感，但丽莎是个狂热的园丁，月中左右，她的朋友们会决定维护她的花园是一个美丽且赋予生命意义的举动，是丽莎想要的。他们会开始每个周末都来除草、修剪、浇水。他们会做一个色彩鲜艳的牌子，上面写着“丽莎的花园”，配上蝴蝶、彩虹，也许还有日出。到 7 月，每周该死的每一天都会有至少一个人在那里工作。
By August, I'll feel guilty riding pass them, and I'll have to go back to putting my bike in my car, driving past Lisa's house, parking at the end of the road, and riding from there.
到 8 月，我骑车经过他们时又会感到内疚，我就又得把自行车放进车里，开车经过丽莎家，把车停在路尽头，然后从那里开始骑。
When I was a child, my favorite book was called The Five Chinese Brothers. It was about five Chinese brothers who all looked exactly alike. When the first brother is sentenced to death, the other brothers trade places with him and use their special powers to save his life. One has an iron neck. One can stretch his legs. One can withstand fire. One can hold his breath forever. The first brother escapes death, and everyone lives happily ever after.
当我还是个孩子时，我最喜欢的书叫《五个中国兄弟》。讲的是五个长得一模一样的中国兄弟。当第一个兄弟被判死刑时，其他兄弟代替他，利用他们的特异功能挽救了他的生命。一个有铁脖子。一个能伸长腿。一个能抗火。一个能永远憋气。第一个兄弟逃脱了死亡，每个人都从此过上了幸福的生活。
I had a brother who died when he was three. His name was Jeffy. I hated him. Jeffy died before I was born, and every dysfunction in my considerably dysfunctional family was blamed on his death, even though he died many years before the dysfunctions actually began.
我有一个三岁时去世的哥哥。他叫杰夫（Jeffy）。我讨厌他。杰夫在我出生前就死了，我那相当失调的家庭中所有的功能障碍都被归咎于他的死，尽管他在功能障碍真正开始的很多年前就去世了。
In the story of my family, the three Jewish brothers, there are no special powers. The first Jewish brother dies. The Jewish father starts to drink. The second Jewish brother comes resent the third Jewish brother. The third Jewish brother takes out his feelings of helplessness on the Jewish sister, who is forever being protected by the melodramatic Jewish mother.
在我家庭的故事里，那三个犹太兄弟，没有任何特异功能。第一个犹太兄弟死了。犹太父亲开始酗酒。第二个犹太兄弟开始怨恨第三个犹太兄弟。第三个犹太兄弟把无助感发泄在犹太姐妹身上，而她一直受到那个戏剧化的犹太母亲的保护。
The lesson learned was simple. Death was something from which you could never move on.
学到的教训很简单。死亡是你永远无法走出的一件事。
By September, as the Jewish holidays approach, I'll start thinking about God. The Jewish High Holidays are all about sin and guilt, punishment and admonition, hell, death, retribution, vengeance. It's the most plunderful time of the year.
到 9 月，随着犹太节日临近，我开始思考上帝。犹太教的高级节日全是关于罪与罚、愧疚、惩罚与警告、地狱、死亡、报应、复仇。这是一年中最抢劫的时光。
I'll consider going to synagogue. I'll wonder if I should be teaching my son more about Judaism. Partially out of an irrational sense of tribalism, but mostly out of an irrational sense of fear. God had taken out Lisa. Maybe he was just working his way up the road, and I was next.
我会考虑去犹太教堂。我会想我是不是应该让儿子多了解一些犹太教。部分出于一种非理性的部落意识，但更多是出于一种非理性的恐惧。上帝带走了丽莎。也许他正沿着这条路往上走，下一个就轮到我了。
By November, I'll begin to worry about Thanksgiving. We've been spending the past few Thanksgivings at Lisa's parents' house, which is close by. Will her parents invite us now that Lisa's passed away? It would kind of suck if they didn't, and I would take it personally, assuming that it meant that they didn't really like us all along, but were just inviting us because of their daughter. I'll obsess about it all month long, and then in mid-November, when they do invite us, I'll obsess about the awkwardness of the meal, now that Lisa won't be there.
到 11 月，我开始担心感恩节。过去几个感恩节我们都是在丽莎父母家过的，离这很近。丽莎去世了，她父母还会邀请我们吗？如果他们不邀请那就太糟糕了，我会觉得很受伤，认为这意味着他们一直都不喜欢我们，只是因为女儿才邀请我们。我整个月都在为这事纠结，然后到了 11 月中旬，当他们真的邀请我们时，我又会纠结于用餐的尴尬，因为丽莎不在了。
They'll probably invite lots of Lisa's friends, thinking that will make it less awkward, but they won't know how sick I am of all her friends already, thereby making a bad situation worse. I'll ask my wife if I can skip the dinner. She'll look at me with the usual disappointment.
他们可能会邀请很多丽莎的朋友，以为这样会减少尴尬，但他们不知道我已经厌倦了她所有的朋友，这反而让情况变得更糟。我问妻子我能不能不去参加晚餐。她用那种一贯失望的眼神看着我。
A few weeks before my grandfather died, my mother asked me to go visit him. His spirits were down. He was refusing treatment and he was talking about wanting to die.
祖父去世前几周，母亲让我去探望他。他情绪低落。他拒绝治疗，还说想死。
I expected to find a miserable old man bitching about life in the golden years, but I didn't. He'd been miserable in bemoaning death, but he was at peace in having accepted it. "I have dozens of grandchildren," he said, "and countless great-grandchildren. I've had a wonderful life and leave behind a beautiful family."
我本以为会见到一个抱怨黄金岁月生活的老人，但我没有。他哀叹死亡时很痛苦，但接受死亡时却很平静。“我有几十个孙辈，”他说，“还有数不清的曾孙。我度过了精彩的一生，留下了美丽的家庭。”
"So why do you want to die?" I asked.
“那你为什么想死呢？”我问。
"Because my pearl is gone," he said, referring to Baba. "I just don't want to be here without her." He wasn't sad. He wasn't morose. He was done.
“因为我的珀尔不在了，”他说，指的是芭芭。“我只是不想在没有她的情况下待在这里。”他并不悲伤。他不忧郁。他是真的放下了。
A few weeks ago, Lisa refused her doctor's advice to go through yet another round of chemotherapy. A close friend of hers died recently, also of cancer, also after having been given a few months to live. Her friend did chemo to the end. The chemo left her nauseous, tired, weak. It would have bought her another month, tops.
几周前，丽莎拒绝了医生的建议，不再接受新一轮化疗。她的一个密友最近也去世了，也是癌症，也是在被告知只剩几个月寿命后。她的朋友化疗到了最后。化疗让她恶心、疲惫、虚弱。那最多只能让她多活一个月。
Sometimes the problem isn't death. it's holding on too dearly to life.
有时问题不在于死亡。而在于对生命的过度执着。
Zaida was done. Lisa is done too. She wants to walk her dogs, and have dinner with some friends, and maybe even take a last long walk through her garden. And then if death comes, it comes.
扎伊达放下了。丽莎也放下了。她想遛遛狗，和朋友吃顿饭，也许最后在花园里散步一次长途。然后如果死亡到来，那就让它来吧。
By December, I'll be glad to see the year coming to an end. I'll be looking forward to getting on with things. Nearly 12 months or so will have passed since Lisa died, and that will feel like an accomplishment. Someone will no doubt decide to have a one year memorial party in Lisa's honor, because that's what Lisa would have wanted, and will leave a message on our answering machine with a time and date, sounding all cheery and excited, but almost too cheery and too excited, because Lisa, after all, is dead. And for a moment I'll feel like I have to go, because, hey, it's for Lisa.
到 12 月，我会很高兴看到这一年即将结束。我很期待继续前行。丽莎去世将近 12 个月了，这感觉像是一项成就。无疑会有人决定为丽莎举办周年纪念派对，因为那是丽莎想要的，他们会在我们答录机上留下时间和日期，听起来欢快又兴奋，但几乎是过于欢快和兴奋了，因为毕竟，丽莎已经死了。有那么一刻，我觉得我必须去，因为，嘿，这是为了丽莎。
But they'll realize, you know what? It's been a year, all right? Why don't you all go to hell. And I'll tell my wife I don't want to go. And by this time, instead of the usual disappointment, she'll look at me and say "Christ, me neither." So we'll lie to everyone and say we're going away on vacation even though we're not, and we'll just make sure to stay out of town for a few days so nobody sees us. Which is exactly what Lisa would have wanted.
但我会意识到，你知道吗？已经一年了，好吗？你们都见鬼去吧。我会告诉妻子我不想去。到这个时候，她不再用那种一贯失望的眼光看我，而是看着我说：“天哪，我也一样。”所以我们会对所有人撒谎说我们要去度假，即使我们并没有，我们会确保在那几天离开城里，这样就没人能看到我们。这正是丽莎想要的。
Shalom Auslander. He's the author, most recently, of the book Foreskin's Lament.
Shalom Auslander。他是《包皮之哀》（Foreskin's Lament）一书的作者，这是他近期的作品。
Act Two. "Lewis Time."
第二章。“刘易斯时间”。
When we were all talking about what to include in this week's show and where we would find interesting predictions for 2010, we realized that teachers are constantly making predictions for the coming year. A good public school teacher has an ongoing diagnosis of where each of their students is and where each of their students is going to end up in June.
当我们都在讨论这周的节目该包含什么内容、在哪里能找到有趣的 2010 年预测时，我们意识到老师们一直在为新的一年做预测。一位优秀公立学校老师会持续评估每个学生目前的水平，以及到 6 月份每个学生会达到什么程度。
Like if I was to show you Lewis' writing, it does not make sense whatsoever.
比如如果我让你看刘易斯的写作，那完全说不通。
Samantha Cato teaches reading and writing to sixth graders at Public School 303 in the Bronx. And she's talking about one of her students, Lewis de la Cruz, who has trouble organizing his ideas when he writes.
萨曼莎·卡托（Samantha Cato）在布朗克斯 303 公立学校教六年级的阅读和写作。她提到了一位学生，路易斯·德拉·克鲁兹（Lewis de la Cruz），他在写作时很难组织自己的思想。
Even listening to Lewis, he's all over the place.
听路易斯说话，也是前言不搭后语。
So where do you want him to be at the end of the year with his reading and writing, and where do you think he will be at the end of the year? I would like, truthfully, for Lewis to write two to three sentences that go together and make sense. And I really do think he can achieve that. I don't know if that's necessarily on grade level, but it's a big step from where we are.
那你希望他在年底时阅读和写作达到什么水平，你觉得他年底会达到什么水平？老实说，我希望刘易斯能写出两到三句通顺且有意义的句子。我真的认为他能做到。我不知道那是否一定达到年级水平，但比起现在已经是很大的一步了。
When it comes to reading, she hopes to have him reading and understanding everything at a fourth grade level. But of course, to accomplish that by June 2010, she's going to have to get him to sit in his seat. Lewis began the year as the most disruptive student in the class. And to deal with that, Ms. Cato and one of the other sixth grade teachers, Ms. Subramaniam, came up with their most ingenious invention-- Lewis time.
在阅读方面，她希望他能达到四年级水平，读懂一切。但当然，要到 2010 年 6 月实现这一目标，她得让他坐在座位上。刘易斯学年开始时是班上最捣蛋的学生。为了处理这个问题，卡托老师和另一位六年级老师苏布拉马尼亚姆老师（Ms. Subramaniam）想出了她们最巧妙的发明——“刘易斯时间”。
Generally, Lewis time begins with Lewis pretending to be a teacher.
通常，“刘易斯时间”开始时，刘易斯会假装自己是一名老师。
This is Ms. Subramaniam.
这是苏布拉马尼亚姆老师。
It's really cute. Sometimes he starts with, "Good morning, boys and girls."
这真的很可爱。有时他会以“早上好，孩子们”开头。
So hi, everybody.
大家好。
Hi, Lewis.
你好，路易斯。
This morning I visited the last school day before Christmas break. And at Ms. Subramaniam's request, Lewis has agreed to do a special 2010 prediction edition of Lewis Time with his predictions for the coming year.
今天早上我在圣诞假期前的最后一个上学日去访问了学校。应苏布拉马尼亚姆老师的要求，路易斯同意进行一期“刘易斯时间”的 2010 年预言特别版。
In 2010, I want to be a famous basketball player in my team.
在 2010 年，我想成为我们队里著名的篮球运动员。
Lewis also predicted a trip that will take him around the world and to Antarctica, where he says he would drink hot chocolate and chill with all the birds.
路易斯还预言了一次带他环游世界并前往南极洲的旅行，他说他会在那里喝热巧克力，和所有的鸟儿一起放松。
Lewis time came about one morning this fall when everybody was still unpacking their stuff and settling in. Lewis popped up at the front of the room, announced, "It's Lewis time," and put on a little show. His teachers, sensing opportunity, decided to turn Lewis time into a reward. Lewis would get to do Lewis time in the morning if he were good the day before, which meant that he--
“刘易斯时间”起源于今年秋天的一个早晨，当时大家还在拆行李、安顿下来。刘易斯突然跑到教室前面，宣布“现在是刘易斯时间”，然后表演了一个小节目。他的老师们感觉到了机会，决定把“刘易斯时间”变成一种奖励。如果路易斯前一天表现好，第二天早上就能有“刘易斯时间”，这意味着他——
Stayed in his seat and stuff like that. And we actually discussed with him, what are the things that you do that are not helping the class learn? And he listed everything. He said, I don't finish my work and I do things to get attention. It was pretty amazing how self-aware he was.
待在座位上之类的。我们实际上和他讨论过，哪些事情是你做的但不利于全班学习？他列出了所有事项。他说，我不完成作业，我做各种事为了博取关注。他对自己有这样的自觉，真是太令人惊讶了。
Sometimes we let the class vote on whether Lewis should have Lewis time. And they're pretty objective about it. I mean, they love that five minutes of the morning, so they all want it, but they are very willing to acknowledge when he doesn't deserve it.
有时我们会让全班投票决定是否进行“刘易斯时间”。他们非常客观。我的意思是，他们热爱早上那五分钟，所以他们都想要它，但当他表现不好不配拥有时，他们也非常愿意承认。
Now we're going to sing for Lewis time. Who's ready? All right.  So [? Jansen, ?] give me  the beat. Lewis time! Lewis time to 8:25. Everybody loves Lewis time.
现在我们要为“刘易斯时间”唱歌了。谁准备好了？好的。那么 [? Jansen, ?] 给我打个节拍。刘易斯时间！刘易斯时间直到 8:25。每个人都爱刘易斯时间。
In fact, everybody does love Lewis time. When he asks for suggestions of participation, hands fly up in the air. Twice in the past, he's called for backup dancers, and each time, three girls stood up and joined him and improvised dance numbers.
事实上，每个人确实都爱“刘易斯时间”。当他征求建议参与者时，大家纷纷举手。过去有两次，他呼叫了伴舞，每次都有三个女孩站起来加入他，即兴跳舞。
Can I ask you, what do you think of Lewis time?
我可以问你，你觉得“刘易斯时间”怎么样？
Funny and it's cool. Like it's fun.
有趣，而且很酷。就很好玩。
If you didn't catch that, she said his grandmother throws farts when she wakes up. Sorry, grandma.
如果你没听清，她说她祖母醒来时会放屁。抱歉了，奶奶。
She was like, mmmm. you know how grandmas are.
她当时说，嗯。你知道奶奶们都是怎么样的。
Lewis time, till 8:25. Lewis time, till 8:25. It's over!
刘易斯时间，直到 8:25。刘易斯时间，直到 8:25。结束了！
Has it changed his behavior?
这改变了他的行为吗？
Yes, a lot. He used to behave really bad. He used to talk back to the teachers. He was really doing bad. He would just get up on his seat when he wants something.
是的，改变了很多。他过去表现真的很糟糕。他过去会顶撞老师。他过去做得真的很差。他想要什么东西时就会直接从座位上跳起来。
Has he changed?
他变了吗？
Yeah, a lot.
是的，变了很多。
Of course, Lewis is just one of 35 students in this class, and there are over 100 sixth graders. And Ms. Subramaniam and Ms. Cato have predictions for where each of them is going to be in June, and a plan for each student. A plan that in this class, the students actually write out themselves. In other words, every one of these students has his or her own much quieter version of Lewis Time.
当然，路易斯只是班里 35 个学生中的一个，而六年级有 100 多名学生。苏布拉马尼亚姆老师和卡托老师对他们每个人 6 月份的去向都有预测，并且为每个学生制定了计划。这个班的学生实际上是自己写下这些计划的。换句话说，这些学生中的每一个都有自己更安静版本的“刘易斯时间”。
Coming up. The President of the United States who's going to be born in the year 2010. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来。将在 2010 年出生的美国总统。节目稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共电台和国际公共电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, 2010. We asked people to predict with as much exactitude as possible things that will happen in their lives and the lives of the people around them in the coming year. We've arrived at act three of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。当然，我们每周都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目是 2010 年。我们要求人们尽可能准确地预测在来年他们自己及周围人生活中将发生的事情。我们现在进入节目的第三幕。
Act Three. "POTUS Operandi."
第三幕。“总统大人”。
Jonathan Menjivar has spent a remarkable amount of time thinking about the coming events of 2010. One event in particular.
乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）花了大量时间思考 2010 年的即将发生的事件。其中一件特别值得关注。
POTUS will have dark, wavy hair. Her eyes will be brown, unless they're green, or maybe hazel. She will have full lips. She will not be tall, which is a nice way of saying that she might be short. Because of this fact, POTUS will not like going to concerts, because like my wife Hillary, she'll only be able to see the backs of other people's heads and that spot on a person's back between their shoulder blades. Someday when she touches that spot on a person she loves, it will feel oddly familiar and comforting, because all her life, while standing in line at the swings, or waiting for a cashier to ring up her milk, she will have looked at that spot on other people.
“总统大人”（POTUS）会有黑色的波浪卷发。她的眼睛是棕色的，除非是绿色，或者可能是淡褐色。她会有丰满的嘴唇。她不会很高，这算是一种委婉说法，意味着她可能会很矮。正因为这个事实，总统大人不会喜欢去听音乐会，因为像我妻子希拉里一样，她只能看到别人后脑勺的后背和后背肩胛骨之间的一点。有一天，当她触碰她所爱之人那个位置时，会感到莫名的熟悉和安慰，因为她一生中，无论是在荡秋千排队时，还是在等收银员结算牛奶时，她都会一直盯着别人身上的那个点。
Because she will be our daughter, POTUS will like chocolate ice cream and enjoy puns. She will need glasses by third grade.
因为她将是我们的女儿，总统大人会喜欢巧克力冰淇淋，喜欢双关语。到三年级她就需要戴眼镜了。
POTUS, I should explain, is what Hillary and I have taken to calling the little girl Hillary will give birth to in 2010. Calling our kid "it" only felt right for about a week or two, so we brainstormed baby code names one night in bed. Hillary thought the name should be something like that opening scene in the West Wing pilot, the one where Rob Lowe walks out of the shower, and a woman in underwear and a men's dress shirt reads from his pager, "POTUS in a bicycle accident." Hillary said our code name should pop like that, but we couldn't think of anything as cool as POTUS, so we just stole it.
我得解释一下，总统大人是我们希拉里在 2010 年将要生下的小女孩的代号。叫我们孩子“它”感觉只对了一周或两周，所以一天晚上在床上我们集思广益想孩子的代码。希拉里认为这个名字应该像《白宫风云》试播集开场的那一幕，罗伯·洛（Rob Lowe）走出淋浴间，一个穿着内衣和男式衬衫的女人读着他的传呼机，“总统大人发生了自行车事故”。希拉里说我们的代号应该像那样引人注目，但我们想不出任何像 POTUS 这么酷的名字，所以我们就直接用了。
I worried that while POTUS was still nothing more than cells splitting into other cells that we might be setting unachievable expectations by naming her the acronym the Secret Service use to refer to the President of the United States. When people find out you're having a baby, they predict all kinds of things about the child you'll have. But I wanted to let POTUS tell us who she was, so I tried to cling mostly to the facts.
我担心，在总统大人还仅仅是细胞分裂成其他细胞时，我们将她命名为特勤局用来指代美国总统的缩写，可能会设定无法实现的目标。当人们发现你要生孩子时，他们会预测你会生出什么样的孩子。但我希望让总统大人告诉我们她是谁，所以我尽量只关注事实。
20 weeks into Hillary's pregnancy, we went in for an ultrasound. Our ultrasound technician looked like Kate from Jon & Kate Plus 8 in scrubs. She had that crazy hairdo and everything. We asked if she could tell the gender of the baby, and she said, "It's a girl." She said it with the same level of enthusiasm I use to tell Hillary that we got a gas bill in the mail.
在希拉里怀孕 20 周时，我们去做了超声波检查。我们的超声波技师看起来就像《强与凯特+8》（Jon & Kate Plus 8）里穿着磨砂服的凯特。她留着那种疯狂的发型，什么都有。我们问她是否能分辨出孩子的性别，她说，“是个女孩”。她说得非常平淡，和我告诉希拉里我们收到煤气费单时的热情程度差不多。
Knowing that POTUS was a girl meant that now there was a shape to the mystery. The ultrasound gave us the lines of a coloring book, and we couldn't help but fill them in.
知道总统大人是个女孩意味着现在这个谜团有了轮廓。超声波给了我们一本涂色书的线条，我们不禁要填充它们。
Hillary remembered all the stuff about dominant and recessive genes that I slept through in my high school biology class, and we thought about our friend Michelle, a biologist who spends her days working with fruit fly genes. I don't really understand what it is she does, exactly, except that it has something to do with diabetes. And this summer, when I was having a fruit fly infestation, she didn't have any suggestions for how I could capture or kill them.
希拉里还记得我高中生物课上睡过去的所有关于显性和隐性基因的东西，我们想到了我们的朋友米歇尔（Michelle），一位生物学家，整天和果蝇基因打交道。我不太明白她究竟做什么，除了和糖尿病有关。今年夏天，当我的家果蝇泛滥时，她没有任何建议告诉我该如何捕捉或杀死它们。
I thought maybe Michelle could help us figure out what POTUS might look like. She said she'd do her best, but that this stuff was more complicated in humans than what I was imagining. She also told me that there was a great paper published in Science recently about the genetics of dog coats, and that if we were breeding a dog instead of a little girl, she could be really helpful.
我想也许米歇尔能帮我们弄清楚总统大人可能长什么样。她说她会尽力而为，但这东西在人类身上比我想象的要复杂。她还告诉我，《科学》杂志最近发表了一篇关于狗皮毛遗传学的很棒的文章，如果我们要繁殖一只狗而不是一个小女孩，她会很有帮助。
So Michelle came over to our house, and in exchange for lasagna and a beer, she sat with me and drew Punnett squares, those little squares divided into four smaller squares that are supposed to help you figure out what traits win over others. Michelle was willing to commit to a few things, like the fact that POTUS will likely have dark hair.
所以米歇尔来到我们家，为了换取千层面和啤酒，她和我坐在一起画旁氏方格，那些被分成四个小方格的小正方形，用来帮你弄清楚哪些特征优于其他特征。米歇尔愿意做出一些承诺，比如总统大人很可能会有黑色的头发。
But really, she said, even if she was able to study me and Hillary in a lab, she couldn't tell us with any certainty what our baby will look like. Because unlike dogs, humans haven't been bred for certain traits, so there's really no way of knowing what green eyes may be hiding in my genes.
但她真的说，即使她能在实验室里研究我和希拉里，她也无法确定地告诉我们我们的孩子长什么样。因为与狗不同，人类并没有为了某些特征而进行繁殖，所以真的没有办法知道我的基因里可能隐藏着什么颜色的眼睛。
Mostly, she said, the whole dominant-recessive thing could help us figure out dopey stuff. Like for instance, now we know that POTUS will have unattached earlobes and be able to impress her friends with her ability to roll her tongue like a taco.
她说，大多数情况下，整个显性-隐性的东西可以帮助我们弄清楚笨拙的事情。比如，现在我们知道总统大人会有分离的耳垂，并能用她像卷饼一样卷舌头的能力打动她的朋友们。
A few months ago, not long after we found out that POTUS was a girl, I was riding my bike home from work. The traffic was heavy, so I was going pretty slow. I looked to my right and noticed a girl on the sidewalk looking at me. Staring, really. She looked like she was in her early 20s and she had her auburn hair tied in a thick braid that swung over her right shoulder. I can't remember if she was wearing glasses, but I know she was wearing a dress and holding a petition clipboard in her right hand.
几个月前，在我们发现总统大人是个女孩后不久，我正骑车下班回家。交通拥堵，所以我骑得很慢。我向右看，注意到人行道上有一个女孩在看我。真的是在盯着看。她看起来 20 多岁，栗色的头发扎成一根厚厚的辫子，垂在右肩上。我不记得她是否戴着眼镜，但我知道她穿着裙子，右手拿着一块请愿板。
If skin was made of Play-Doh, hers was what you would get if you forever mixed the Hillary color with the Jonathan one. I couldn't tell you if it was that or the way she looked at me intently that's to blame, but I stared back. And for a split second, I thought she might be POTUS, all grown up.
如果皮肤是用培乐多（Play-Doh）做的，她的皮肤就是你把希拉里的颜色和乔纳森的颜色永远混合在一起得到的结果。我没法告诉你是因为那个，还是因为她盯着我看的神情，我也回盯着她看。一瞬间，我想她可能是总统大人，长大了。
I wanted to ask her so much, how's school? Do you live around here? What do you like more, seeing fireflies for the first time in the summer or the first fat snowflakes in winter? Really, though, every question was some variation on the one big question I'll try my whole life to make POTUS answer yes to. Are you happy?
我有太多的问题想问她，学校怎么样？你住这附近吗？夏天第一次看到萤火虫，还是冬天第一场大雪，你更喜欢哪个？但实际上，每一个问题都是我一生中试图让总统大人回答“是”的那个大问题的变体。你快乐吗？
It's also, I realize, a question I can't predict the answer to.
我也意识到，这是我无法预测答案的一个问题。
Jonathan Menjivar is one of the producers of the radio show Fresh Air in Philadelphia.
乔纳森·门吉瓦是费城电台《新鲜空气》（Fresh Air）节目的制作人之一。
Act Four. "Nostra-Mom-Us."
第四章。“诺查丹玛斯妈妈”。
For our next predictions for 2010, we leave the United States, and we turn to one of our regular contributors, Etgar Keret, who lives in Tel Aviv.
对于我们 2010 年的下一次预测，我们要离开美国，转向我们的一位常驻撰稿人，住在特拉维夫的埃特加·凯雷特（Etgar Keret）。
I live in a family of predictors, but they're mostly predictable predictors. With my ultra-Orthodox sister, it always comes down to the messiah being just around the corner. While with my anarchist brother, it's more along the lines of a blissful economic catastrophe that will liberate this planet from its social injustice. My four year old son Lev predicted next year I'll be moving out of his apartment, and he'll finally get some quality bedtime with his mother without me snoring in the background. And there's my dad. But he being one-track minded, will reply to any question with his usual pitch about how our entire family should buy a piece of land, build a huge mansion, and live in it together, hippie-style, minus the sex and drugs.
我住在一个预言家家庭，但他们大多是可预见的预言家。我那笃信正统派的姐姐，结论总是弥赛亚即将来临。而我那个无政府主义的哥哥，则更倾向于一场令人愉悦的经济大灾难，将这个星球从社会不公中解放出来。我四岁的儿子列夫（Lev）预言明年我会搬出他的公寓，他终于能和他母亲享受高质量的睡前时光，而不用背景里有我打呼噜。还有我爸爸。但他有单轨思想，对任何问题都会回答他那套老话，关于我们全家应该买一块地，建一座大豪宅，住在一起，像嬉皮士那样生活，只是没有性和毒品。
The only person in the family who is a good predictor is my mom. So prediction-wise, I'm stuck with her. This woman told me when I was 12 years old that my favorite soccer club would never win any title, and the last 30 years have proven her right.
家里唯一一个靠谱的预言家是我妈妈。所以说到预测，我只能靠她了。这个女人在我 12 岁时告诉我，我最喜欢的足球俱乐部永远不会赢得任何冠军，过去 30 年证明她是对的。
She also predicted that my brother's first marriage would end in divorce. Admittedly, my future sister-in-law called the wedding "religious performance art," sold tickets to it, and during the ceremony, insisted on breast feeding a porcupine. So maybe it should have been clear to all of us what was coming. But I was at that wedding too, and I was willing to bet a porcupine that they would stay together forever.
她还预言我哥哥的第一次婚姻会以离婚告终。诚然，我未来的嫂子把婚礼称为“宗教表演艺术”，还卖票，在仪式上坚持给一只豪猪喂奶。所以也许我们所有人应该清楚接下来会发生什么。但我也参加了那场婚礼，我愿意打赌一只豪猪，他们会永远在一起。
And then about four years ago, my mother predicted her next door neighbor's heart attack. Some people may see this incident as more of a curse than an ability. Still, this woman has powers.
然后大约四年前，我母亲预言了她隔壁邻居的心脏病发作。有些人可能认为这种事更像是一种诅咒而不是能力。尽管如此，这个女人确实有力量。
So when I'm asked to give a prediction about Israel and the Middle East for 2010, I go running to mommy.
所以当有人让我对 2010 年的以色列和中东做出预测时，我跑去问我妈。
Mom, they've asked me for this American radio show to give my prediction about what's going to happen in Israel next year and its [UNINTELLIGIBLE].. So I thought I'd come and ask for your help. Do you have any visions about the future?
妈，美国电台让我对以色列明年会发生什么做出预测……所以我来找你帮忙。你对未来有什么愿景吗？
Yes, I do. Unfortunately, they are not very nice. We are going back to bad times. It will be a third intifada. The third one won't be so free like they are. We won't be able to walk in the evening. You don't know what will hit you. Because all the crazy people from both sides will show their hand. And then it will be very difficult to live in this country.
有，有的。不幸的是，它们不太好。我们又要回到糟糕的时代了。这将是第三次大起义。第三次不会像之前那样自由。我们晚上将无法散步。你不知道什么会打击你。因为双方所有疯狂的人都会露出真面目。那样在这个国家生活会非常困难。
So now I want to do something that is very intuitive. So I'll just say a word, and you say the first thing that comes to your mind.
现在我要做一件非常直觉的事情。我说一个词，你回答第一个闪现在你脑海里的词。
OK.
好的。
OK. God.
好的。上帝。
What?
什么？
God.
上帝。
Well, what about him?
好吧，他怎么了？
How would Israel look different if there would be no God, if everybody's decision would be atheist?
如果根本没有上帝，如果每个人的决定都是无神论的，以色列会是什么样子？
It's impossible to think of.
这不可能想象。
So God these days is part of the equation. We can't take him out.
所以这些日子上帝是等式的一部分。我们不能把他拿出来。
No way, no way. Middle East without God doesn't exist. There's no such thing.
没门，没门。没有上帝的中东是不存在的。没这回事。
And the year of 2010 for me, for Etgar, what do you think is going to happen to me in 2010.
关于 2010 年对我，对埃特加，你认为 2010 年我会有什么事发生。
Oh, you're going to flourish. This is your year.
哦，你会繁荣昌盛。这是属于你的一年。
Can you try and build a solid case for that, just so I'll feel better?
你能试着为此找个充分的理由吗，好让我感觉好点？
You write a book. You direct a film. And you'll be a success. And hopefully, my grandson Lev will have a sister or a brother, and I'll be very happy. Our family will be fine.
你写本书。你导演一部电影。你会成功的。希望我的孙子列夫会有个妹妹或弟弟，我会非常高兴。我们家庭会好好的。
Thank you, mother.
谢谢你，母亲。
Here is the bottom line for my mother's 2010 prediction. The region is going to burn. People will die. And somehow, things are going to be horrible for everyone but me. Sorry everyone. I guess my mother's gut is telling her that our country, our wold, is going down the drain. But her heart just can't admit I'm part of that world.
这就是我母亲 2010 年预测的底线。这个地区将要燃烧。人们会死去。而不知何故，除了我之外，所有人都会过得很惨。抱歉大家。我想我母亲的直觉告诉她，我们的国家、我们的世界正走向毁灭。但她的心无法承认我是那个世界的一部分。
Since I just started saving money for my four year old son's college education in a region where an innocent word like "tomorrow" sounds dangerously hopeful, I'm for sure my mother's son.
因为我刚开始为我四岁儿子的大学教育存钱，而在一个像“明天”这样纯洁的词听起来都充满危险希望的地区，我肯定是我母亲的儿子。
Etgar Keret. His most recent book of short stories translated into English is The Girl On the Fridge.
埃特加·凯雷特。他最新翻译成英文的短篇小说集是《冰箱上的女孩》（The Girl On the Fridge）。
Act Five. "Funny You Don't Look Two-Ish."
第五章。“真奇怪你看起来不像两岁”。
The biggest question that lots of us have about 2010 is, is the economy finally going to get better?
我们很多人对 2010 年最大的疑问是，经济最终会好转吗？
Well, making predictions about that is a very big business. Economists at every government in the world, every state in the union, at big banks and big private companies, have spent the last couple weeks finishing up their 2010 forecast. It's probably hundreds of thousands of man hours and hundreds of millions of dollars devoted to seeing into the future.
嗯，做这方面的预测是一项大生意。世界上每个政府、每个州、各大银行和大私营公司的经济学家，过去几周都在完成他们的 2010 年预测。这可能是数十万工时和数亿美元投入到预见未来上。
And knowing that we're all going to be hearing these forecasts in the news around this time of year, for our last story on today's show, we asked Alex Blumberg and Adam Davidson to explain to us what do these forecasters know and what don't they know?
知道我们每年这个时候都会在新闻里听到这些预测，对于今天节目的最后一个故事，我们请阿历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）和亚当·戴维森（Adam Davidson）向我们解释，这些预测者知道什么，不知道什么？
We asked around. We asked former Fed officials and big shots at major banks. And they told us if money is no object and you really want to know the economic future, here's who you call. A firm named Macroeconomic Advisers and its forecasting wunderkind, Joel Prakken.
我们打听了一下。我们询问了前美联储官员和大型银行的大佬。他们告诉我们，如果钱不是问题，你真的想知道经济未来，你应该找谁。一家名为“宏观经济顾问”（Macroeconomic Advisers）的公司及其预测神童乔尔·普拉肯（Joel Prakken）。
The Department of Treasury is a client of ours. The Office of Management and Budget. The CBO. The Federal Reserve Board is a client of ours. Many of the regional Federal Reserve banks. Many central banks from around the world are clients of ours, in fact. Almost any household name on Wall Street is a client of ours.
财政部是我们的客户。管理和预算办公室。国会预算办公室。美联储理事会是我们的客户。许多区域性联邦储备银行。事实上，来自世界各地的许多中央银行都是我们的客户。华尔街上几乎任何家喻户晓的名字都是我们的客户。
Right.
对。
What makes Macroeconomic Advisers so special is their computer model that they've made of the entire U.S. economy. Now of course, a lot of forecasters use computer models, but theirs is unusually comprehensive. This has been Joel Prakken's life's work. He's been carefully studying how different parts of the economy affect each other.
“宏观经济顾问”的特别之处在于他们制作的美国经济模型。当然，很多预测者使用计算机模型，但他们的模型异常全面。这一直是乔尔·普拉肯毕生的工作。他一直在仔细研究经济的不同部分如何相互影响。
You know, if you think about it, it's pretty obvious that if average wages go up, if people make more money, they'll buy more stuff. But how much more stuff? That is where Joel's model comes in. If wages go up by, say, 4%, how many more cars will people buy? And what will that do to the inflation rate? And how will the inflation rate affect home sales? In an economy, everything is connected. Everything is related.
你知道，如果你想一下，平均工资上涨，如果人们赚更多钱，他们会买更多东西，这是显而易见的。但多买多少？这就是乔尔模型发挥作用的地方。如果工资上涨，比如 4%，人们会多买多少辆车？这对通胀率有什么影响？通胀率会如何影响房屋销售？在经济中，一切都是相连的。一切都是相关的。
And for the past 28 years, Joel has been figuring out those exact relationships and writing those relationships down in a series of equations which he shows us. And in the world of economic forecasting, showing us those equations is like showing us the secret recipe for Coca-Cola.
在过去的 28 年里，乔尔一直在计算这些确切的关系，并把这些关系写成了一系列方程式，他展示给我们看。而在经济预测领域，向我们展示这些方程式就像展示可口可乐的秘方一样。
Although frankly, Prakken's a lot less worried about the secret getting out than Coca-Cola is. He's very happy to show us his equations, because what are we going to do, steal them? We can't even understand them.
尽管坦率地说，普拉肯对秘方泄露的担心比可口可乐少得多。他非常乐意向我们展示他的方程式，因为我们能做什么，偷走它们吗？我们甚至看不懂。
If we scroll down a little bit further to look at some of the equations--
如果我们向下滚动一点看看其中的一些方程式——
What?
什么？
Yeah, OK. So here is an equation-- yeah.  So--
是的，好的。所以这是一个方程式——是的。所以——
Whoa! It gets worse every day.
哇！每天都在变糟。
It does get worse.
确实在变糟。
So to get at what this equation looks like on the radio, I'm going to read it. It says ECDO over KCDO subscript negative one equals--
为了在广播里弄清楚这个方程式长什么样，我要读一下它。它写着 ECDO 除以 KCDO 下标负一等于——
Which means last period's, minus one. That subscript minus one means last period's KCDO.
意味着上一期的，减一。那个下标减一意味着上一期的 KCDO。
OK. Equals 0.16 plus 0.006008 times DUM 92 plus 4.447867 times the change in KH plus--
好的。等于 0.16 加上 0.006008 乘以 DUM 92 加上 4.447867 乘以 KH 的变化加上——
The log of KH.
KH 的对数。
Oh, the log of KH.
哦，KH 的对数。
So don't miss that.
所以别错过那个。
Plus 17 over, I don't even know what--
加上 17 除以，我甚至不知道是什么——
Sigma. That's the sum of alpha of the change--
西格玛。那是 alpha 的总和，变化——
Right. One of you remembers your Greek. It's the summation.
对。你们中有人记得希腊字母。那是求和符号。
Right. And I didn't even get done reading the equation. There's still a whole other line.
对。我还没读完方程式。还有整整一行。
Yeah. You did half of the equation.
是的。你只读了一半方程式。
I think you probably read enough.
我想你读得足够多了。
Now, I just want to point out, also. So this one page here-- there are, what? I'm looking at the pdf. It says there's 400--
现在，我也只想指出。所以这一页——这里有，什么？我在看 pdf。上面说有 400——
You're on page 49 of 447.
你在第 447 页中的第 49 页。
Somewhere an economics grad student is listening to that and thinking, "oh, you SUM alpha to an n of 17!" Right?
某个经济学研究生正在听那个，心想，“噢，你把 alpha 求和到 n 为 17！”对吧？
Joe let us play around with his model. And it was fun. It was like as much fun as I've ever had with a computer screen full of numbers. You can change one thing and watch the effect ripple out throughout the economy. Like we made Joel pretend a war broke out in Saudi Arabia and the average price of oil went from $70 to $100. Boom! Unemployment went up for the next three years.
乔尔让我们玩了他的模型。这很有趣。就像我玩过满是数字的电脑屏幕一样有趣。你可以改变一件事，观察其影响如何在整个经济中扩散。比如我们让乔尔假装沙特阿拉伯爆发了战争，石油的平均价格从 70 美元涨到了 100 美元。砰！失业率在接下来的三年里上升了。
It's like a real world Sim game, sort of. And Joel says that sometimes even his clients want to play. They're constantly asking him to show the worst worst case scenarios. What if everything goes wrong? He's not actually sure this helps them plan anything, but he does it for them.
这有点像现实世界的模拟游戏。乔尔说有时连他的客户都想玩。他们总是要求他展示最坏的最坏情况。如果一切都出错了会怎样？他其实不确定这是否有助于他们规划任何事情，但他还是为他们做了。
Now, most of the data Prakken plugs into his model is free. Anyone can download it from government websites. And you'd think that the data would be the simple part of all this. There's no fancy math. It's just facts. Like how many people were unemployed in 2008, for example.
现在，普拉肯输入模型的大多数数据是免费的。任何人都可以从政府网站下载。你会认为数据应该是所有这一切中最简单的部分。没有奇特的数学。只是事实。比如 2008 年有多少人失业，例如。
But it turns out, even the data is not simple. And this points to a big problem in forecasting. Joel was showing us how he puts new data into the model, and this was data from a government agency called the BEA, the Bureau of Economic Analysis. For those of you who aren't accountants, the third quarter of 2009 ended in September. But Joel only gets the data from the third quarter around Christmas, three months after the quarter has already ended. And that data, it's not firm. In fact, the BEA calls it an estimate.
但事实证明，即使数据也不简单。这指出了预测中的一个大问题。乔尔正在向我们展示他如何将新数据输入模型，这是来自一个叫 BEA 的政府机构的数据，即经济分析局。对于你们中不是会计的人来说，2009 年的第三季度在 9 月份结束。但乔尔直到圣诞节，在季度结束三个月后才得到第三季度的数据。而那些数据，并不确定。事实上，BEA 称之为估计。
What's called the final estimate for third quarter GDP.
这就是所谓的第三季度 GDP 的最终估计。
Wait, they have to estimate what happened three months ago? They can't even get a firm number on what happened in the past?
等等，他们必须估计三个月前发生了什么？他们甚至无法得到过去发生的事情的确切数字？
Well, they make three estimates-- well, they make many estimates of what happened the previous quarter. We have the first estimate of the third quarter. A month later, a second estimate. A month after that, a third estimate. In July of every year, we get a so-called annual revision of that, so that's a fourth estimate. July after that, we get the fifth. July after that, we get the sixth.
嗯，他们做出三次估计——嗯，他们对前一个季度发生了什么做出许多估计。我们有了第三季度的第一次估计。一个月后，第二次估计。再过一个月，第三次估计。每年 7 月，我们得到所谓的年度修正，所以那是第四次估计。再过一年 7 月，我们得到第五次。再过一年 7 月，我们得到第六次。
Wait, you mean it's like three years after the year that we--?
等等，你的意思是这就像我们——之后三年？
Right. There are so-called three year revisions to GDP that go back three years.
对。有所谓的三年期 GDP 修正，追溯到三年。
But I just want to point out, we're calling you to ask what 2010 is going to be like. And what I'm hearing is, if we're lucky, by summertime you can tell us what 2007 was like.
但我只是想指出，我们打电话给你问 2010 年会是什么样子。而我听到的是，如果我们幸运的话，到夏天你可以告诉我们 2007 年是什么样子。
Well, if we're lucky, by July of this year, we'll have our first true annual estimate of what 2009 was like. We'll have our second true annual estimate of what 2008 was like. And we'll have our third true annual estimate if what 2007 was like.
嗯，如果我们幸运的话，到今年 7 月，我们将有我们对 2009 年是什么样子的第一次真实年度估计。我们将有我们对 2008 年是什么样子的第二次真实年度估计。我们将有我们对 2007 年是什么样子的第三次真实年度估计。
And you're not even telling us-- when will we actually know?
你甚至没告诉我们——我们到底什么时候会知道？
You know, you never know for sure, I think, is the answer here.
你知道，我想答案永远不会确定。
They just give up guessing.
他们只是放弃猜测了。
And then on occasion, the BEA introduces a new and improved methodology for processing all the source data, and will revise the entire history of GDP all the way back to 1929 to reflect the improved methodologies.
有时 BEA 会引入一种新的、改进的方法来处理所有源数据，并会修正 GDP 的整个历史，一直追溯到 1929 年，以反映改进的方法。
Economists have a joke which speaks exactly to this point. They say, "How can we predict the future? We can't even predict the past."
经济学家有一个笑话恰好说明了这一点。他们说，“我们怎么能预测未来？我们甚至不能预测过去。”
Yeah. We found all these different economist jokes on this subject. And a lot of them get sort of wonky. Like here's one example. "There are two types of economists-- those who can't forecast interest rates, and those who do not know that they can't forecast interest rates."
是的。我们在这个主题上发现了所有这些不同的经济学家笑话。其中很多有点古怪。比如这是一个例子。“有两种经济学家——那些不能预测利率的，和那些不知道他们不能预测利率的。”
Or my personal favorite, attributed to that great economic forecaster Yogi Berra, "The hardest thing to forecast is the future."
或者我个人最喜欢的，归功于伟大的经济预测家尤吉·贝拉（Yogi Berra）的一句话，“最难预测的是未来。”
Now, all these jokes point to a pretty dismal reality. Economic forecasters, even the best, just are not that good at forecasting the economy.
现在，所有这些笑话都指向一个相当惨淡的现实。经济预测者，即使是最好的，也不擅长预测经济。
We have this chart that shows how they've done over the last 20 years. On average, the best economic forecasters, including Prakken's Macroeconomic Advisers, have been off by an average of one percentage point per year in predicting how good the economy will do.
我们有这张图表展示了他们过去 20 年的表现。平均而言，包括普拉肯的“宏观经济顾问”在内的最好的经济预测者，在预测经济表现方面平均每年偏差一个百分点。
Now, that might sound pretty good, one percentage point. But in economic forecast, that can be the difference between night and day, or recession and growth. If a forecast is for the economy to grow by 2% next year, a percentage point error margin means it'll grow somewhere between 1% and 3%.
现在，那听起来可能很不错，一个百分点。但在经济预测中，那可能是白天和黑夜，或衰退和增长的区别。如果预测明年经济增长 2%，一个百分点的误差幅度意味着它将在 1% 到 3% 之间增长。
But 1% growth is really bad. That doesn't even keep up with the population growth. It means there's going to be more unemployment, more layoffs. That's a grim economy.
但 1% 的增长真的很糟糕。那甚至跟不上人口增长。这意味着会有更多的失业，更多的裁员。那是黯淡的经济。
3% is the exact opposite. Unemployment will go down. People will start feeling better. They'll build homes and start new businesses.
3% 则完全相反。失业率会下降。人们会开始感觉更好。他们会建造房屋并开始新的企业。
And that 1% margin of error, that's in a good year. Worst case, these forecasts completely miss a huge economic upheaval. For example, our most recent economic upheaval. In January of 2008, right before the economy collapsed, the leading forecasters were predicting a pretty decent year. In fact, we now know the worst recession in decades had already begun. And not only did they not forecast it, they didn't even notice that it had already started.
而且那个 1% 的误差幅度，是在好年头。在最坏的情况下，这些预测完全错过了巨大的经济剧变。例如，我们最近的经济剧变。在 2008 年 1 月，经济崩溃前夕，领先的预测者还在预测一个相当不错的年份。事实上，我们现在知道数十年来最严重的衰退已经开始了。他们不仅没有预测到，甚至没有注意到它已经开始了。
By the way, economic forecasters also missed the 1982 recession, the 1984 recovery, the late '90s stock bubble, the 2001 recession. So you get the idea.
顺便说一句，经济预测者也错过了 1982 年的衰退、1984 年的复苏、90 年代末的股票泡沫、2001 年的衰退。所以你明白这个意思了。
You know, economic forecasting is inherently an impossible task.
你知道，经济预测本质上是一项不可能完成的任务。
This is MIT economist Simon Johnson. Listeners might recognize his voice. He's been the show before. We were talking to him because of his former job as an economic forecaster. He was actually the chief economist at the IMF, the International Monetary Fund, where he was responsible for delivering the IMF's annual economic forecast. Which he says was pretty stressful, because he knew there were all these things he didn't know.
这是麻省理工学院经济学家西蒙·约翰逊（Simon Johnson）。听众可能认出他的声音。他以前上过节目。我们和他谈话是因为他曾做过经济预测的工作。他实际上是国际货币基金组织（IMF）的首席经济学家，负责发布国际货币基金组织的年度经济预测。他说这压力很大，因为他知道有所有这些他不知道的事情。
Between now and the end of next year, the world will bd hit by three major shocks, probably.
从现在到明年年底，世界大概会遭遇三次重大冲击。
You mean that's just average, over the last century or whatever?
你的意思是那只是平均水平，过去一个世纪之类的？
Yes, exactly. Stuff happens, OK? And you know, the thing you're studying is subject to so much chaos in a mathematical sense. So much randomness. Relatively small random things that can have big outcomes. Because there's a lot of nonlinearity, if you want to use a technical expression, in the way this system operates. And so making any forecast has inherently got this problem.
是的，完全正确。事情发生了，好吗？你知道，你研究的东西在数学意义上受制于太多的混乱。太多的随机性。相对较小的随机事物可能产生巨大的结果。因为如果你想用技术术语，这个系统的运作方式有很多非线性。所以做任何预测本质上都有这个问题。
Talking to to Simon, you realize chaotic randomness is just one of many problems confronting an economist trying to make a forecast. For example, in Simon's case, there are politics involved, as well. Simon was constantly getting pressure from other countries to revise his IMF forecast. He even got in a famous tussle-- famous in the world of international finance, at least-- with the French and German governments when they said his forecast was too downbeat.
和西蒙交谈，你意识到混乱的随机性仅仅是经济学家试图做预测时面临的众多问题之一。例如，以西蒙的情况为例，还涉及政治。西蒙不断受到来自其他国家的压力，要求他修改国际货币基金组织的预测。他甚至与法国和德国政府闹出了一场著名的争执——至少在国际金融界很有名——当时他们说他的预测太悲观了。
But Simon says global politics is not the only non-mathematical factor that throws off forecasts. There's also your own ego.
但西蒙说，全球政治不是唯一影响预测的非数学因素。还有你自己的自我。
You know, the hardest thing about forecasting, actually, is that you get too committed to the forecast. You get too committed to what you said last time. Because it's just too embarrassing to say, oops. You know, I was wrong. A lot of stuff happened. We misread it. We have to make a big revision. People hate to make big revisions to their forecasts, and I'm no exception.
你知道，做预测最难的事情实际上是你对预测投入太多。你对上次说的话投入太多。因为说“哎呀”太尴尬了。你知道，我错了。发生了很多事。我们读错了。我们必须做出重大修订。人们讨厌对他们的预测进行重大修订，我也不是例外。
This happened to me, actually, this year. This year we had, I think, a lot of good analysis. We make some good calls early in the year. And then one of the people are I work with very closely started to say, you know, I think there's going to be a recovery. And I said, how can there be a recovery? We've pointed out all these massive problems. We've very wedded to this view that we're going down and we're staying down. And you know, he pointed out to me that economies usually bounce back, even economies with deep-seated problems, for example, the bank system can bounce back in this sort of situation.
这实际上发生在我身上，今年。今年我想我们有很多很好的分析。我们在年初做出了一些好的判断。然后和我密切共事的一个人开始说，你知道，我认为会有一个复苏。我说，怎么会有复苏？我们指出了所有这些巨大的问题。我们非常坚持这种我们正在下滑并保持下滑的观点。你知道，他向我指出，经济通常会反弹，即使是有根深蒂固问题的经济，例如，银行系统在这种情况下也会反弹。
And I realized that I had to get over-- you know, the fact that I diagnose problems had convinced that the initially negative forecast had been a good call, and then I was still staying negative when I should've revised positive.
我意识到我必须克服——你知道，我诊断出问题的事实让我相信最初的负面预测是一个好的判断，然后当我应该修正为正面时，我仍然保持负面。
But it's hard to change your mind like that. You've told people, you've stuck you neck out, you've been to events, you've said, I think it's going to be, you know, it's going to be flat from here. And you realize that that's-- you have to go out and say, I've changed my mind. I've updated. That's not an easy thing to do when you went around telling people. And yet you were quite convincing when you told people all these negative things.
但要改变那样的想法很难。你告诉过人们，你已经把脖子伸出去了，你参加过活动，你说过，我认为会是，你知道，从现在开始会是平坦的。你意识到那是——你必须出去说，我改变主意了。我更新了。当你到处告诉人们时，那不是一件容易做到的事。然而当你告诉人们所有这些负面的事情时，你是很有说服力的。
Now I've got to say, Simon, you did make some very strong predictions in January, February of this year that I found incredibly persuasive. Which were that basically, if I recall correctly, if the U.S. government does not take over several of our leading banks, we are in for a severe, long-term financial crisis akin to the Lost Decade in Japan, where basically there was no economic growth for a long, long, long time. It seems right now you were wrong on that, right?
现在我不得不说，西蒙，你在今年 1 月、2 月确实做出了一些我觉得非常有说服力的非常强有力的预测。那就是基本上，如果我没记错的话，如果美国政府不接管我们的几家主要银行，我们将面临严重的、长期的金融危机，类似于日本的“失去的十年”，基本上有很长很长很长一段时间没有经济增长。看来现在你在那一点上错了，对吧？
Yes, I was wrong. And that's a hard thing to say. And I think that Adam just called me on it in a most embarrassing fashion. I'm blushing deeply here. Because, you know, it's hard for me to say-- how am I going to get out of that one?
是的，我错了。那是一句很难说出口的话。我想亚当刚刚以最尴尬的方式指出了这一点。我在这里脸红得厉害。因为，你知道，我很难说——我该怎么摆脱那个？
One guy who is constantly confronted with the limits of economic forecasts is Randy Moore. He puts out the very influential Blue Chip Economic Indicator newsletter, which compiles the 50 leading economic forecasts. Randy averages them out and produces what's called the Blue Chip Consensus Forecast, the distilled thinking of the 50 best economic minds in American businesses.
兰迪·摩尔（Randy Moore）是一个不断面对经济预测局限性的人。他发布非常有影响力的《蓝筹经济指标》（Blue Chip Economic Indicator）通讯，汇编了 50 家领先的经济预测。兰迪将它们平均，产生了所谓的“蓝筹共识预测”，即美国商业界 50 位最优秀经济头脑的精髓思考。
Now, the Blue Chip Forecast Newsletter does not come cheap. It'll cost you $875 for a year subscription.
现在，《蓝筹预测通讯》并不便宜。一年的订阅费要 875 美元。
Though that's nothing compared to Joel Prakken's Macroeconomic Advisers. That's like 20 to 100 grand a year, right?
尽管那与乔尔·普拉肯的“宏观经济顾问”相比什么都不是。那是一年 2 到 10 万美元，对吧？
Yeah, but you get a much bigger forecast. And both these guys have lots of customers. Governments are using them to plan budgets and make decisions about taxing and spending. Banks use it to decide who to lend money to and where to invest their extra money. Companies use the information to figure out how many people to hire or fire, or how much steel to buy, or whatever. It has a huge impact.
是的，但你得到了一个更大的预测。这两个家伙都有很多客户。政府利用它们来规划预算，并做出关于征税和支出的决定。银行利用它来决定借钱给谁以及在哪里投资他们的额外资金。公司利用这些信息来弄清楚雇佣或解雇多少人，或购买多少钢材，等等。它有巨大的影响。
But for a guy who makes his living selling economic forecasts, Randy is pretty honest about how accurate he thinks they are.
但对于一个靠销售经济预测为生的人来说，兰迪对这些预测的准确性相当诚实。
Any economic forecast that you see that includes a decimal point implies a level of accuracy that reality suggests isn't present.
你看到的任何包含小数点后的经济预测，都暗示了一种现实中并不存在的准确程度。
So you would rather if most forecasts just ended with -ish? Like, it'll be two-ish, it'll be three-ish.
所以如果大多数预测只是以“-ish”（左右）结尾，你会更喜欢吗？比如，会是 2% 左右，会是 3% 左右。
Just two. Two-ish, three-ish, exactly.
只是两点。2% 左右，3% 左右，完全正确。
I love that idea. That we should make a-- not make a law, but we should encourage economists to just end with -ish. The economy will be three-ish. It'll be good-ish.
我喜欢那个主意。我们应该制定一个——不是法律，但我们应该鼓励经济学家只是以“-ish”结尾。经济将是 3% 左右。会是好一点。
Unfortunately, that's not what the consumers of economic forecasts want. People that want those forecasts want decimal point forecasts.
不幸的是，那不是经济预测消费者想要的。想要那些预测的人想要小数点后的预测。
But that's so interesting to me, is that the people who are using these forecasts, they want a level of precision that they themselves have to know, by experience, is just not possible.
但这对我来说太有趣了，使用这些预测的人，他们想要一种连他们自己根据经验也一定知道根本不可能的精确程度。
I agree with that.
我同意这一点。
What's going on there?
那里发生了什么？
I don't have a ready explanation for that. It's difficult to plug in a two-ish number. Excel doesn't recognize two-ish or three-ish.
我没有现成的解释。很难插入一个 2%-ish 的数字。Excel 不识别 2% 左右或 3% 左右。
You know, people have been going to oracles since the days of Delphi. And I don't think anybody that shows up has the expectation that it's going to be completely right. But there's comfort in being told that. And I think that's probably what those decimal points are.
你知道，人们从德尔斐时代起就一直去求神谕。我不认为任何去的人都有它会完全正确的期望。但被告知那些令人感到安慰。我认为这可能就是那些小数点的原因。
But of course, what are people supposed to do? One economic forecaster we talked to told a story about being on the board of a small not-for-profit. They were trying to figure out how to balance their budget for the coming year, what to charge for services. At one point in the discussions, a board member looked to this economist and said, "Where do you think interest rates will be next year?"
但当然，人们该怎么办？我们谈过的一位经济预测家讲了一个故事，关于他在一家小型非营利组织的董事会。他们试图弄清楚如何为来年平衡他们的预算，对服务收取多少费用。在讨论的某一点，一位董事会成员看着这位经济学家说，“你认为明年的利率会在哪里？”
Sort of the economist's version of asking a doctor, "This mole, you think I should get it looked at?"
有点像经济学家版的问医生，“这个痣，你认为我应该去检查一下吗？”
So there this economist was, with all these people looking at him like, you're the expert! You know what the future is. Tell us. And the economist could not just say, I have no idea. The future is void. The organization needed to stay open, the budget needed to be balanced, fees needed to be set. He needed to make a forecast.
所以这位经济学家就在那里，所有这些人看着他，就像，你是专家！你知道未来是什么。告诉我们。而经济学家不能仅仅说，我不知道。未来是虚无的。该组织需要保持开放，预算需要平衡，费用需要设定。他需要做出一个预测。
I would call it a necessary evil.
我会称之为必要的恶。
Again, Simon Johnson.
又是西蒙·约翰逊。
You know, there's so much imprecision. There's so much lagging in terms of our updating that, in some sense, we'd be better off without forecasts. We'd be better off making up our minds afresh every day. But the problem is, you can't do that.
你知道，有太多的不精确。在我们的更新方面有太多的滞后，在某种意义上，没有预测我们会更好。我们每天重新拿定主意会更好。但问题是，你做不到。
All of these, the businesses, the institutions, all involve thinking about the future and planning for the future. And you can't do that without taking a view of the future.
所有这些，企业、机构，都涉及思考未来和规划未来。而你不能在不采取一种未来观点的情况下做到这一点。
In other words, there's one thing we can say for sure about the future. It will come. And just because we don't know what it will bring doesn't mean we shouldn't make our best guess.
换句话说，关于未来我们可以确定地说一件事。它会到来。而且仅仅因为我们不知道它会带来什么并不意味着我们不应该做出我们最好的猜测。
Alex Blumberg and Adam Davidson are the creators of Planet Money, which is a co-production of our program and NPR News. They explain the economy in normal language that anybody can understand on their thrice-weekly podcast and blog at npr.org/money.
阿历克斯·布隆伯格和亚当·戴维森是《星球货币》（Planet Money）的创作者，这是我们节目和 NPR 新闻的联合制作。他们每周三次在播客和 npr.org/money 的博客上用任何人都能理解的正常语言解释经济。
Our program is produced today by Jane Feltes with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Aaron Scott. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Our music consultant is Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）与阿历克斯·布隆伯格、萨拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿莉莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）制作。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。制作帮助来自亚伦·斯科特（Aaron Scott）。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。我们的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who can be seen lurking around the public radio conventions, luring radio hosts to come work at WBEZ with these words.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。WBEZ 对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他常被看到潜伏在公共广播大会周围，引诱电台主持人来 WBEZ 工作，说的就是这些话。
You're the one. When I tell you you're going to be successful, I don't mean kind of successful. I mean successful in a way that you rarely see. I mean really successful. And you just need to get ready.
就是你了。当我告诉你你会成功时，我指的不是那种程度的成功。我指的是你鲜少见到的那种成功。我指的是真正的成功。你只需要做好准备。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。